hello aspiring teachers sal here from  the not-for-profit khan academy and all  of us at khan academy and ets makers of  the praxis core exam recognize that  teachers are the most essential part of  a learning experience and that's why  today we are excited to announce the  launch of official praxis core prep from  khan academy and ets to truly level the  playing field and broaden the pipeline  of teachers throughout the country  aspiring teachers are going to be able  to come to khan academy get diagnostics  and work on math reading and writing and  understand what your gaps are the  software will adapt to allow you to work  on what will be highest leverage for you  to prepare for the praxis core and  beyond this is completely free it is not  for profit and we're confident that if  we give you this little help that you'll  be able to run with it and impact  generations of students to come